well in the old days it really was true
they all used to beat each other
senseless and you know have sex with
each other because there were no girls
around I mean they lived in these
completely women free environments from
the time they were 9 to the time they
got out of college and they get out of
college and it would just be the strange
creatures women they couldn't deal with
it and the country was really run by men
so they're all doing with each other
yeah there was a real homophobic streak
in the society so they had to do it and
pretend they weren't doing it and the
beating you know really went on until
the end of the 90s it was then finally
made it legal but in men you know these
men were all in this weird situation
where they it was a kind of sexual
thrill I think and that's why they all
love Margaret Thatcher because she was
this kind of you know figure of
authority and maybe a figure of pain a
little bit and I you know the right of
Christopher Hitchens told me this
hilarious story about how he years and
years ago when she was not prime
minister but was the head of the
Conservative Party he wrote a piece
where he said he's sort of fancied her
you know she was kind of sexy he thought
and he met her once and he sort of he
said I felt maybe there was this little
free song going on and we started
talking about foreign policy and it was
kind of sexy and they disagreed about
something and and she said she said no
you're wrong and he said no I'm right
and she said no you're wrong and their
little thing and then he said bend over
and she hit him on the bed on his butt
with his with her papers from Parliament
you know like her little things that the
order of the day papers and his she she
did that and she said naughty boy don't
do that again and you know that's the
kind of thing they all they have this
like little titillating naughty boy
thing about them themselves and and you
know there was that guy recently was
head of Formula One racing who got
caught it going to prostitutes and
apparently wanting to them to dress up
like Nazi camp operators and then also
inmates in a concentration camp and
there's a lot of kind of weird spanking
and speaking in German
or during each other around and his
defense he sued for invasion privacy and
he actually won but his defense was look
okay I did it so what you know this is
what people do if I want to get my kicks
you know spanking people dressed in
German yeah you know costume good for me
and actually he won his case which was
really interesting and he didn't the
thing is he didn't go to like sexual
rehab clinic or or say you know god I
have a real problem i'm gonna stop doing
this he said this is what i like to do
sue me